liz may sociation obédiences et après
d'attaqué par une différentes questions
des échanges sous la tutelle
bienveillante de notre rapporteur
donc je propose à madame anaïs anselme
et à monsieur charleville g de commencer
alors avant tout on tenait vous remercie
naturellement le rapporteur et et
monsieur le président de cette
invitation sur cette mission
d'information nous sommes donc le forum
français de la jeunesse porte parole des
organisations animé et géré par des
jeunes en france avec un but donc de
rassembler des organisations diverses
afin de la faire de la co-construction
de politiques publiques notamment sur ce
on a décidé de vous propose enfin de
vous présenter sur deux axes principaux
que sont l'orientation et l'insertion
des jeunes avec à chaque fois une petite
un petit état des lieux et quelques
préconisations
alors avant tout l'orientation des
jeunes qui naturellement est une
variable clé pour comprendre les
situations de précarité et qui est un
gros facteur d'inégalités parce que les
et les inégalités se répercute
évidemment sur l'insertion
professionnelle ce qui va donner de la
précarité des jeunes une absence
d'égalité des chances des possibilité
d'émancipation réduite notamment
l'orientation se fait à tous les niveaux
collège lycée études supérieures et
c'est un facteur donc de reproduction
des inégalités notamment de la classe
sociale du genre et en particulier de
l'ancrage géographique de nombreux
travaux montrent la reproduction forte
de ces inégalités avec l'obtention des
diplômes notamment avec une
hiérarchisation de ceux ci les grandes
écoles en sont un très bon exemple avec
une majorité de femmes une
sur-représentation pardon des classes
sociales qui sont aisés
et une sous représentation des
territoires ruraux et donc ça c'est en
particulier pour le l'origine sociale
mais aussi pour le genre avec moins de
30% de femmes dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs en 2017 là aussi par
exemple l'orientation est plus souvent
contrarié aussi en fonction des
inégalités géographiques qui en
particulier là aussi dans les dents les
cuvées et les territoires ruraux avec
aussi lorsqu'on a une orientation subie
plus facilement du décrochage parce que
l'orientation subi est un facteur qui
qui fait le décrochage on a aussi avec
les mythes qui sont les plus précaires
qui sont aussi ceux évidemment qu'ils
sont sans diplôme
donc on a là aussi un lien fort entre
orientations et précarité sur les idées
sur les autres inégalités notamment
l'obésité mais aussi les noms avec
consonance maghrébine on peut voir que
là aussi on a 1 entrée dans le marché de
l'emploi qui est beaucoup plus difficile
pour ces personnes-là notamment pour les
femmes obèses 7.2 mois de probabilité de
trouver un emploi selon une note de
l'insee
alors quelles préconisations là dessus
le forum français de la jeunesse
préconise la mise en place d'un service
public de l'orientation de l'information
et de l'accompagnement allant du
secondaire à l'entrée dans la vie active
mais aussi tout au long de la vie
l'objectif étant de donner des moyens
forts à cette orientation pour élever le
niveau des jeunes ce qui va du coup en
lire naturellement avec l'égalité des
chances organiser la poursuite de
formation en parcours autour notamment
de voir en adéquation avec leurs
aspirations et leurs capacités et un
accompagnement personnalisé et
collectifs par les pairs et là dessus on
le coche de comité d'orientation des
politiques de jeunesse travaille aussi
sur des problématiques et sur des
préconisations similaire sur
l'orientation professionnelle
on a là aussi un taux de chômage en
europe qui est
20 kg et qui augmente légèrement
notamment avec la crise mais qui est
toujours inférieur à celui de la france
sachant que la france est l'un des cinq
premiers pays d'europe avec le taux de
chômage de plus haut
contrairement au chômage global de la
population le les jeunes sont en quelque
sorte la variable d'ajustement
en fait quand on emploie plus on emploie
fut d'abord les jeunes malheureusement
ceux qui sont en insertion
professionnelle et notamment avec des
difficultés donc naturellement avec
l'orientation des difficultés de
l'acquisition de compétences mais aussi
de mobilité de santé de logement de
maîtrise du numérique de discrimination
et notamment raciale qui ne favorise pas
leur insertion professionnelle
et là aussi en un mot quelques
préconisations du forum français de la
jeunesse une rémunération et une
politique de manière générale sur les
stages avec une rémunération améliorée
et dès le premier jour
et de manière un petit peu plus large la
mise en place du cv anonyme sur le lieu
d'habitation
ce qui ce qui toucherait directement
pour le coup les employeurs et de la
part de l'état la mise en place du rsa
et de la garantie jeunes pour tout ça
merci
lucile bertho est bien aussi tout
d'abord merci aussi pour votre
invitation pour parler de l'égalité des
chances
tout d'abord le cnajep pour resituer
c'est une coordination qui rassemble 70
mouvements nationaux de jeunesse
éducation populaire et du coup le cnajep
permet à ces associations en fait des
des espaces de dialogue et de
concertation et aussi de représentation
auprès des pouvoirs publics sur les
questions de jeunesse et d'éducation
populaire le cnajep souhaite plutôt
aborder cette question d'égalité des
chances plutôt sur le volet de
l'émancipation
ce qu'en fait les anticipations est au
coeur du projet d'éducation populaire
et notamment des du beaucoup de
dassault qui sont d'associations qui
sont membres du tournage s est dit qu'on
voulait plutôt parler de de ramener
cette question de l'émancipation
voilà du coup on peut dire que voilà un
jeune de haute saône
un jeune qui habite à paris ou en
seine-saint-denis déjà en fait elles
n'auront pas de chance dès le départ
l'idée alors l'origine de terry mère
alliés à leurs origines de vie et du
coup je voulais reprendre un chiffre par
exemple sur l' enquête provoque ce qui
est sûr les jeunesses et les
opportunités du coup c'est lié au
dialogue structuré qui a été mis en
place l'année dernière 80 % des jeunes
en qui était disent qu'il ya plus
d'opportunités en ville qu'à la campagne
voilà du coup ça montre déjà des
indicateurs que les opportunités ne sont
pas les mêmes selon les territoires
bref en tout cas en fait le cnajep du
coup souhaite parler d'une politique
jeunesse d'émancipation avec un parcours
sécurisé est choisie par chaque jeune et
du coup on voulait le décliner en quatre
axes sur la multi mobilité culturelle
et spatiales sur l'engagement et puis
aussi sur tout ce qui est loisirs et
culture du coup j'ai lespaul prendre la
suite
[Musique]
madame le rapporteur la surprise non
mesdames et messieurs nationale si chère
collègue que je rencontre pour la
première fois en présentiel bonjour donc
on a souligné ici je vais m'atteler
discuter donc de la mobilité culturelle
et spatiales dans un premier temps on
pourra éventuellement en échange et par
la suite
et quant à la mobilité culturelle
l'accès aux vacances par exemple créer
des mixités par l'émancipation et
favoriser l'égalité des chances
ça permet à des jeunes de découvrir
davantage de choses d'apprendre à vivre
en collectif et la question est de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on favorise le
départ en vacances pour toutes et tous
comment est-ce qu'on permet de créer des
espaces de rencontres donc entre jeunes
issus de différentes origines sociales
dans un cadre qui soit sans la diversité
la mixité sociale permise sur ces temps
de vacances sont bénéfiques pour
l'ensemble des parties prenantes c'est
doivent être promues et jusque dans
l'enseignement supérieur et au delà par
exemple l'année passée l'union nationale
des centres sportifs de plein air ucpa
organisé en partenariat avec le crous
une édition d'un bus pour un campus qui
avait permis donc d'investir le départ
en vacances de
d'étudiantes et d'étudiants en santé qui
avait participé à l'effort de la crise
sanitaire mais également de personnes
issues de milieux défavorisés ou en tout
cas étant identifiés comme des personnes
en situation de précarité dans
l'enseignement supérieur donc sur le
critère débourse donc sur qatar sociaux
mais également de différentes
possibilités au niveau de certaines
épiceries où il était bénéficiaire
ces dispositifs sont à renforcer et
semble être une piste assez intéressante
donc pour favoriser encore une fois pour
en faire le lien avec le thème
l'émancipation est également l'égalité
des chances par le partage de valeurs
communes comme l'a souligné charles
également le cas sur la mobilité
spatiale
lorsque l'on entend ce thématique il
s'agit de l'aborder sous un prisme à ses
transversales mais ici on peut en dire
que le sujet est intrinsèquement liée à
la question de l'accompagnement fiscale
du jeune mais la mobilité au sens
premier du terme est davantage une
erreur la manière dont on va
décloisonner effectivement l'accès des
personnes issues de milieux ruraux donc
donc en mobilité vers des milieux
plusieurs mois il ya des choses qui sont
déjà mises en place comme certaines
bourses à la mobilité mais d'autres
éléments comme les universités
numériques par exemple qui peuvent se
trouver en milieux ruraux sont peut-être
à développer comment est-ce qu'on va
permettre à d'autres publics comme des
néo diplômés ou des personnes en
recherche d'emploi de s'insérer
professionnellement et socialement sans
être confronté à cette barrière de la
mobilité spatiale
on pourrait effectivement également
disputé sur le temps d'échanger
la question du logement quant à elle
et bien constitue le premier poste de
dépenses chez les jeunes est pourtant
est un des premiers vecteur
d'émancipation d'égalité des chances
puisque étant également un des premiers
vecteurs de réussite dans l'enseignement
supérieur
les perspectives sont du plan 60000 qui
en septembre 2019 a fait l'objet d'un
rapport qui mettait en exergue les
difficultés de son déploiement notamment
la baisse des appels qui pouvait seul
viabiliser les les locataires mais
également sécurisé des bailleurs ou
alors le simple fait d'augmenter le plan
40000 au plan 75 euros en fait simple en
80 milles sans en augmenter les moyens
donc comment comme demander leurs
sentiments par rapport à cette politique
aux politiques menées
quant au décloisonnement au niveau de la
mobilité assez réservés mais certaines
menu mesures doivent être soulignés
comme la dispositif visage par exemple
la facilitation de parc hlm dont qui est
au récent donc au public jeune ou encore
des actions intergénérationnelles it et
qui fleurissent dans des corps
associatif et institutionnel et qui sont
à promouvoir
voilà pour la partie sur la mobilité
culturelle espace ya la question des
loisirs du sport et de la culture en
fait je sais pas je fous à détailler
davantage mais cool et voilà c'est un
vecteur en tout cas d'émancipation et
qui permet aussi de rencontrer d'autres
personnes et du coup le cnajep soutien a
du coup à ce que ce tissu associatif
généralement soit du coup elle a soutenu
par les pouvoirs publics
voilà qui du coup ils sont un acteur
important en tout cas
dans un parcours d'émancipation et
ensuite on voulait a terminé sur
l'engagement du coup l'engagement en
fait c'est pour nous un vecteur
d'émancipation dans le sens que voilà on
permet à des jeunes notamment si on l'a
on parle des jeunes aujourd'hui de mieux
comprendre déjà dans quel environnement
eu du pif de mieux consiste en le
conscientiser voilà dans quelle société
iv est aussi il permet aussi de prendre
des responsabilités et ses
responsabilités du coup aussi amène à
acquérir des savoirs des savoir-faire et
de savoir-être
du coup puisque le cnajep en tout cas
propos c'est qu'ils ont d'honneur en
tout cas les la possibilité aux jeunes
de d'emprunter emprunté des parcours
d'engagement qui s'arrête en a qui sont
assez diverses et variées qui peuvent
être du coup les parcours dans
l'animation volontaires être animateur
animatrice bafa
il ya aussi les missions de service
civique aussi qu'ils sont propositions
d'engagements et puis il y à aussi
prendre des responsabilités s'engager
dans les associations
du coup pose la question aussi comment
on donne il faut qu'on donne la place
aussi du coup assez jeune dans les
associations et du coup il ya la
question du rhône du renouvellement
aussi et ça peut aussi cette question
qui peut s'élargir aussi dans les
espaces politiques aussi dans les
annales les institutions voilà comme le
sénat par exemple tout autre voilà et
pour terminer en fait pour que
construire ce parcours et sécurisé est
choisi en fait il faut travailler avec
les organisations les plus actives de
jeunes et du coup ça ramène la question
aussi de la gouvernance des politiques
jeunesse aujourd'hui en france du coup
on souhaite davantage pour choses et
aussi le rôle de la région qui est chef
de file à mais qui est pas assez porter
sur sa actuellement est aussi le lien
aussi de l'état
sur ça et aussi la place des jeunes
aussi qui sont très peu présents dans
les espaces de co construction des
politiques publiques et qui seront qui
serait pour nous un élément majeur en
tout cas pour avoir des politiques
publiques efficientes et voilà après il
ya des choses déjà existants notamment
le dialogue structuré qui a animé par le
cnajep et qui permet du coup à des
jeunes de construire des propositions et
de les porter auprès des décideurs
politiques
voilà pour nous mesdames c'est à vous
merci bonjour madame messieurs
alors avant toute chose merci merci de
nous recevoir dans ce temps des changes
autour des inégalités des jeunes alors
avant de commencer je voulais je vais
représenter en quelques mots le mrjc
donc le mrjc donc mouvement rural de
jeunesse chrétienne est une association
de jeunes et d'éducation populaire dont
qui est portée par des jeunes de 13 à 30
ans c'est une association qui est
présente en milieu rural et qui
accompagne finalement des jeunes à
prendre des responsabilités à s'engager
sur les territoires où ils vivent et à
s'émanciper pour devenir des citoyens
citoyennes engagées
donc concrètement ça passe notamment par
des espaces type séjour formation à
l'animation à des sujets de société et
globalement des temps d'action en
collectif voilà en quelques mots et du
cou avant de commencer on
on voulait aussi vous redire quand on
voit qui il n'existe pas une seule
jeunesse si on a bien il ya bien des
jeunesses pluriel tout avec leurs
particularités et notamment nous c'est
aussi au plus tôt au nom de jeunes
ruraux que nous venons parler en
particulier de celle qu'ont rejoint dans
nos actions
du coup pour introduire nous les
facteurs d'inégalités que nous
identifions et que nous souhaitons
souligner aujourd'hui viennent sont
plutôt autour de l'accès à des
conditions dignes d'existence et des
conditions d'engagement de jeunes ruraux
donc je vais les faits maximilienne
bonjour dans les dents les difficultés
qu'ont qu'on peut constater les
difficultés d'insertion professionnelle
des jeunes issus des territoires ruraux
c'est pas nouveau à ces difficultés
elles sont quand même présente depuis un
certain temps on peut citer notamment le
rapport du ceser sur la place des jeunes
dans les territoires ruraux qui a été
publié en janvier 2017 qui pointe qu'un
quart des jeunes ruraux et rurale de 18
à 24 ans sont sans emploi ou sans
formation
du coup c'est quand même un chiffre
assez important
on sait que les propositions d'études ou
d'emploi dans les zones rurales elles
sont plus rares qu'en zone urbaine et
que du coup ça nécessite ça amène un
besoin de mobilité assez tôt dans son
cursus pour pouvoir prolonger son cursus
de formation mais aussi s'insérer dans
le monde dans le monde du travail
donc ça amène aux questions de mobilité
donc il ya des questions de mobilité à
l'intérieur de son territoire pour
pouvoir se déplacer au quotidien soit
pour sa formation soit pour un emploi on
sait que dans les territoires hausse et
des territoires peu desservi en
transports publics et donc la nécessité
d'avoir son véhicule ou en tout cas son
propre moyen de se déplacer et qui sont
des conditions nécessaires à l'obtention
d'un emploi pour la plupart des endroits
on a aussi du coût des migrations vers
un autre territoire donc notamment quand
on veut faire une poursuite d'études
mais aussi pour pour trouver un emploi
mais du coup ces migrations elle amène
une réalité économique différente c'est
à dire qu'il faut trouver un logement il
faut pouvoir payer son transport
ça aussi peut créer pour certains
certaines un bas de s'éloigner de son de
sa famille de ses amis voilà de son
réseau affectif et social
voilà voilà là dessus et puis sur
d'autres questions assez rapide ya aussi
la question de les questions de mobilité
elles sont en lien avec les questions
d'insertion en tant qu' en tant que
jeunes et notamment sur la question de
comment on a accès à un logement alors
qu'elle a déjà été souligné
tout à l'heure voilà donc on souligne
qu'il ya quand même des politiques de
services d'accès au logement
même si elles sont encore elles sont
encore améliorable voilà
on très rapide et puis enfin là pour
pour faire synthétique et puis on sera
profond né veut bien répondre à des
questions précises d'haïti sur ces
questions ouais et du coup je vais
continuer aussi sur les constats
comporte plutôt autour de la question de
l'engagement l'accès à l'engagement et
et aux loisirs
parce que la question de la mobilité et
puis elle a des propositions
relativement rare dans territoires
ruraux pour déjà ne concerne aussi
finalement des questions les
propositions d'engagements et de loisirs
et du coup rappelé aussi que le
développement de soi la construction de
son parcours et l'émancipation passe
aussi par des espaces de rencontre et
d'engagement
on peut avoir au quotidien et du coup
nous en tant qu'acteur d'éducation
populaire en milieu rural on ne peut que
témoigner de la nécessité de cette
proposition pour chaque jeune et ça peu
une proposition pour chaque jeune ça
passe ça signifie aussi des propositions
de proximité qui sont en lien avec les
réalités et les aspirations qui sont
propres aussi à une zone géographique
et puis et puis à des réalités locales
ça passe aussi par des fins signifie
aussi des espaces de rencontres des
espaces sont autistes du lien social
et puis des espaces collectifs pour pour
se construire et s'émanciper et bien sûr
cette notion de collectif aussi que nous
souhaitons insister sur sur la manière
de se construire aussi au sein d'une
société et nous notre constat
aujourd'hui est que ces propositions
sont finalement moins enfin peu denses
en territoire rural et puis que
certaines mesures tendent aussi à
uniformiser les propositions
d'engagements notamment par par des
financements qui qui sont plutôt de type
labellisation et donc voilà qui viennent
parfois remettre en cause la diversité
des propositions est alors à la suite de
ces de ces constats on a aussi quelques
préconisations pour permettre des
conditions de vie dignes chacun et
chacune sur le territoire au moins se
trouve donc ceux concernant l'accès à
l'emploi on constate qu'il ya des
garanties jeunes on parle aussi de nous
on est sur comment on peut on peut la
développer comment aussi on peut le rsa
il peut être ouvert aux moins de 25 ans
pour être un filet de sécurité mais qui
n'est pas qui est bien sûr un filet de
sécurité mais dans l'idée de travail et
l'accès à l'emploi
il ya aussi des questions les questions
noble idée comment on permet d aide d
aide à l'accès au permis à l'accès aux
premiers véhicules et aussi comment on
développe bain des transports en commun
de transport partagé sur les territoires
concernant les responsabilités pour nous
ça nous semble important que les jeunes
niçois ils soient associés aux décisions
qui les concernent notamment à tous les
échelles que ce soit à l'échelle de la
commune à l'échelle
intercommunalité aussi du département
ont comme aujourd'hui de pouvoir en
échanger avec vous sur les visions qu'on
peut avoir des jeunes dans les
différents territoires mais aussi qu'ils
soient associés sur des politiques
jeunesse mais sur aussi d'autres sujets
puisqu'ils sont des habitants et
habitantes du territoire de là où ils
sont et puis donc on parlait de des
espaces d'engagement comment aussi on se
il ya des soutiens aux espaces
d'engagement qui sont proposées aux
espaces de rencontres qui sont proposées
aux jeunes via des soutiens des soutiens
financiers des moyens diverses et de la
valorisation des espaces d'engageant qui
peut être présents sur un territoire
merci pour votre aide merci monsieur
mais ici beau s'il vous plaît bonjour je
suis heureux d'intervenir au nom de la
jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne sur la
question des politiques en faveur de
l'égalité des chances et de
l'émancipation des jeunes et je vous
remercie de votre invitation
la jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne c'est la
première association nationale de jeunes
du milieu ouvrier et des quartiers
populaires elle rejoint plusieurs
milliers de jeunes âgés de 13 à 30 ans
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
depuis 1927 la joc a construit une
expertise sur la vie des jeunes par son
contact permanent avec le terrain sa
présence sur l'ensemble du territoire et
aussi par des enquêtes faites
régulièrement auprès de milliers de
jeunes sur différentes thématiques de
leur vie comme l'emploi la réussite et
la liberté de choix les discriminations
etc
les inégalités qui touchent les jeunes
du milieu ouvrier et des quartiers
populaires elles sont nombreuses et
elles ont de réels impacts sur leur
choix de vie tout d'abord les jeunes
sont touchés par une égalité dans
l'accès à un emploi
nous vivons
un chômage de masse en france depuis des
années et la jeunesse est la plus
touchée
alors que le taux de chômage moyen en
france oscille entre 7 et 9% aux deux
derniers trimestres de 2020 dans le même
temps celui ci il est supérieur à 20 %
chez les 15 24 ans on reproche aux
jeunes bien souvent dans l'entrée sur le
marché du travail leur manque
d'expérience
les jeunes du milieu ouvrier et des
quartiers populaires sont encore plus
touchées par ces inégalités d'accès à
l'emploi cas ils n'ont pas les moyens
bien souvent de faire des études longues
et bien souvent ils n'ont pas accès à un
réseau qui facilite leur entrée dans le
monde du travail
ils sont souvent obligés de prendre le
premier emploi disponible pour avoir un
revenu et subvenir à leurs besoins et
non pas le choix d'exercer le métier qui
souhaiteraient ensuite les jeunes issus
de quartiers populaires sont aussi
touchés par les inégalités géographiques
et notamment en termes de mobilité
ça a été soulignée par plusieurs
organisations présentes et au niveau des
quartiers populaires ces quartiers sont
ne sont pas ou très mal desservi par les
transports en commun et ça crée un
isolement géographique des personnes qui
vivent qu'ils sont notamment éloignée
des centre villes
le manque d'emplois aussi dans certains
endroits condamne les jeunes à devoir
bouger là où il ya de l'emploi
pour pouvoir en trouver hélas tous n'ont
pas les moyens d'être mobile que ce soit
par les transports en commun ou par un
véhicule personnel déjà dans le cursus
scolaire et d'études ça se ressent
comment postuler librement pour un stage
dans l'entreprise qu'on souhaite
si on n'a aucun moyen de s'y rendre et
que les transports en commun ne
permettent pas d'y accéder à angers par
exemple dans leur recherche de stage les
jeunes issus de quartiers populaires
sont restera un postuler dans des
entreprises qui sont proches
une des lignes de bus qui desservent
leur quartier ensuite les jeunes du
milieu ouvrier et des quartiers
populaires ont des ressources
financières qui sont limitées et qui les
oblige à faire des choix
c'est aussi un frein pour l'accès à un
logement les prix des loyers sont
parfois trop élevés pour que des jeunes
se permettent de prendre un logement et
bien souvent les gratification de stage
ou des indemnités de service civique mme
de garantie jeunes ne sont pas
suffisantes pour vivre et assume un le
voyez enfin les jeunes font aussi face à
une égalité d'accès à l'information et
aux droits en particulier les jeunes en
apprentissage ne connaissent pas
toujours leur droit au travail et
beaucoup se font avoir par manque
d'information le manque de réseaux
frappent là encore ces jeunes qui bien
souvent rencontrent des difficultés à
trouver une entreprise prête à les
accueillir le temps de leur formation
toutefois on souligne qu'un travail a
été mené depuis plusieurs années sur
l'apprentissage
la filière a été revalorisé et il est
important de continuer à améliorer
l'image de cette filière professionnelle
pour tous les jeunes qui la choisissent
et qui s'épanouissent dans ces métiers
alors pour permettre une réelle
émancipation de la jeunesse pour la job
qu'il faut prendre en considération les
jeunes tels qu'ils sont les écouter
respecter leur envie leur donner les
moyens de construire leur vie et leur
projet librement ainsi que les moyens de
suivre la voie qu'ils ont choisie
ensuite la lutte contre les inégalités
d'accès à l'emploi elle passe par la
lutte contre le chômage de masse qui
accentue encore plus les inégalités dont
les jeunes des quartiers populaires sont
victimes
il faut également donner les moyens aux
jeunes d'être mobile localement et
notamment en facilitant la desserte des
quartiers populaires vers les
centres-villes dans l'offre de transport
en commun pour ne pas enfermer les
jeunes dans leur quartier enfin trop de
jeunes aujourd'hui ne bénéficient pas
des aides auxquelles ils auraient droit
car ils ne savent pas qu'elles existent
ou car les démarches à faire ne sont pas
toujours accessibles ou trop compliqué
trop complexe et pour lutter contre ce
nom recours une solution serait
d'automatiser l'attribution des droits
sociaux aux jeunes qui peuvent en
bénéficier
merci merci
le show colis c'était vous oui merci
merci monsieur le président madame les
rapporteurs messieurs mesdames les les
les sénateurs et sénatrices je voulais
vous remercier de m'inviter du fait du
renouvellement du cs 2 c'est sûrement
une de mes dernières prises de parole et
puis
après avoir présenté du coup sérieux à
la fois le faut renforcer la jeunesse et
le mrjc et puis je suis vice président
du cce au nom des organisations
étudiantes et mouvements de jeunesse
et puis avec dont je commence à en moins
de légitimité à représenter les
organisations de jeunes donc ça se
termine et peut-être ça vaudrait le coup
d'ailleurs d'interroger ou d'avoir un
échange sur l'impact qu'a la présence
des organisations de jeunes dans une
institution comme celle du cee qui a été
me semble utile en tout cas marquante
par cette ce premier mandat
[Applaudissements]
peut-être joue les trois parties une
première revenir sur la question des
jeunes ruraux en effet ça a été plutôt
notamment le travail que j'ai pu mener
avec la prit une présidente de chambre
d'agriculture danièle evain sur au sein
du cce sur la place des jeunes dans les
territoires ruraux porter un regard sur
la question des politiques publiques
menées et puis un peu sur le en terme de
prospective les actions possibles pour
la suite sur la question des jeunes dans
les territoires ruraux
ce travail là il a permis de marquer
quatre caractéristiques quiconque qu'ont
les jeunes sur ce territoire là il me
semble-t-il qui sont aussi des facteurs
des inégalités internes quatre
caractéristiques la première c'est sur
leurs questions delà des parcours
scolaires et d'entrer dans la vie active
maximilienne on en a parlé un peu on
sait que les jeunes ruraux ont plutôt
des meilleurs résultats jusqu'à la fin
du collège
et ce qui montre une capacité de
rattrapage même de l'école dans les
territoires ruraux ce qu on sait qu il
ya d d d origine sociale et
professionnelle ont eu davantage de
catégories populaires dans les
territoires ruraux et à la suite on
choisi majoritairement les voies
professionnelles plus de 50% des ruraux
contre 40% des urbains du coup il ya des
choix qui sont fortement déterminés à la
fois par des déterminismes sociaux
c'est-à-dire quand on vient d'un milieu
populaire échos autour de soi on a
plutôt des gens qui sont
inscrits dans ces filières courtes ont
fait des études plus courte et puis sur
l'accessibilité de l'offre
en gros on va c'est très difficile quand
on est un petit village de se rendre de
faire médecine par exemple conseillé
dans une agglomération très lointaine
d'ailleurs ce qui a eu aussi une
problématique aujourd'hui la
désertification médicale
et puis admin entrée dans la vie active
qui est quand même particulièrement
compliqué ce que le chiffre que donner
maximilienne un quart des jeunes des
territoires ruraux qui se retrouvent
sans emploi et sans formation du fait
notamment de l'éloignement des lieux de
formation et d'accompagnement sur ces
territoires
le deuxième c'est sur la question de
l'engagement et de la prise en compte
par les politiques publiques ce que
montrer le travail du cee
c'est que il ya des jeunes ruraux qui
s'engage plutôt plus que l'ensemble de
la jeunesse qui sont appliquées sur leur
territoire et pour autant qu'ils sont
pas pris en compte et pas impliqué dans
les politiques publiques
il existe moins de politique en leur
direction dans ces territoires là du
fait d'un certain nombre de questions et
sur lequel on pourra revenir sur les
raisons de sa en tout cas c'est pas une
priorité des politiques dans ces
territoires là il ya une faiblesse de 2
c de c politique
al'inverse un peu de ce qu'il peut
exister dans les agglomérations ont pour
y revenir et le résultat de ça c'est une
forte défiance forte défiance des jeunes
des territoires ruraux vis-à-vis de la
politique 92 % des jeunes ruraux ne font
pas confiance dans la politique et c'est
c'est des chiffres qui s'aggrave d'année
en année ce qui est avec une forme de
radicalisation qui a une vraie
inquiétude me semble-t-il pour la suite
la troisième caractéristique qui
ressortait de ce travail là c'est les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes qui sont bien plus marquée que
sur l'ensemble des territoires ont dans
la question de l'orientation il y avait
encore un un article aujourd'hui dans le
monde sur l'assignation social qui est
fait en particulier des jeunes filles
sur ces territoires là mais aussi des
territoires sociaux des espaces sociaux
qui sont bien plus penser en direction
des garçons que des filles
et c'est une vraie problématique qui va
jusque dans l'emploi où il ya quand même
des les emplois les plus précaires etc
qui sont aujourd'hui
dans le sont réservés en tout cas qui
sont majoritairement occupés par des
femmes ça c'est la troisième
caractéristique la quatrième ça a été
évoqué c'est la question de la mobilité
les jeunes des territoires ruraux sont
la population rurale la plus impactée
par les questions de mobilité parce que
les espaces dont ils ont besoin d'auto
école de gynéco ex terrasson les les
les services qui sont les plus éloignés
de ce territoire là ça ça a des
répercussions très forte à la fois
budgétaire sur l'employabilité
c'est un tiers des jeunes qui n'a pas pu
assister à un entretien liées à l'emploi
dans ces territoires la faute de
mobilité les deux tiers disent qu'ils
pourraient répondre à plus d'offres s'il
n'avait pas de problème de mobilité
ça a des impacts également sur la
question du loisir de l'accès à la
culture mais aussi de l'accès aux soins
une des découvertes de ce travail là
c'était de montrer que c'est l instant
en 2017 je suis pas sûr que c'est
vraiment changé le premier département
consommateurs d'héroïne stella meuse
ce qui n'est pas forcément ceux dont on
pense de prime abord
voilà un peu très rapidement à la hache
quelques caractéristiques en tout cas
qui montre des inégalités qui sont
fortes pour les jeunes de ces
territoires là sur le regard des
politiques menées ces dernières années
je me suis posé la question lesquelles
c'est à dire que je crois que depuis
2000 il n'y a pas eu de politique
jeunesse en tant que tel de porter dans
les années 2000 il ya eu un certain il
ya en tout cas la volonté d'avoir un
certain nombre de politiques structurées
sur la question de l'emploi des emplois
jeunes
un certain nombre de dispositifs de
participation avec envie d'agir le
conseil national de la jeunesse extra
qui se met à danser ce qui se met en
route dans ces années là et depuis on a
assisté plutôt un enchaînement de
mesures le service civique à certain
nombre d'appels à projets des choses qui
peuvent être par ailleurs tout à fait
intéressant mais qui n'ont pas structuré
une politique jeunesse
d'autant plus que dans la même période
ce à quoi on a assisté c'est la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
politiques qui étaient structurantes en
direction de la jeunesse c'est la
disparition par exemple des djs qui sont
là intégré mais qui ne représente plus
rien sur les territoires et qui en tout
cas n'ont plus la capacité d'accompagner
c'est pour eux ce que je connais mieux
sur les territoires ruraux la
disparition par exemple d'une ligne du
ministère de l'agriculture en direction
de l'animation rurale qui a mis à plat
un certain nombre de structures mjc et
xterra sur ces territoires là et qu'une
vraie aujourd'hui difficultés parce que
en tout cas c'est le travail qu'on avait
fait il ya une perte voire sur un
certain nombre de territoires ya plus
d'acteurs d'éducation populaire qui
propose un certain nombre de choses aux
jeunes et du coup on a cru notamment en
2017 avec la loi égalité citoyenneté qui
pourrait y avoir aussi engagé les
organisations de jeunes sont largement
engagés dans ces dans cette construction
là et pour autant il ya eu plutôt une
déception à la fin c'est le chef de file
à des politiques jeunesse qui a été dit
mais qui a pas vraiment aujourd'hui de
substances dans les conseils régionaux
c'est le conseil d'orientation des
politiques jeunesse jeunesse qui fait un
très bon travail mais qu'il craint mais
écoutez qui n'est pas suffisamment
écoutés voilà et puis dernièrement un
certain nombre de mesures qui continue
et qui sont un peu me semble-t-il
incompréhensible en tout cas pour de mon
point de vue c'est la question par
exemple du tutorat tout à fait
dernièrement typiquement me semble-t-il
quand le tutorat devient une politique
d'état c'est sa lutte pas contre les
inégalités et le risque en plus ces deux
plutôt renforcé le sentiment
d'arbitraire c'est à dire que
si tu trouve le bon parent etc tu
pourras t'en sortir si tu le trouves pas
tant pis pour toi quoi
et du coup il ya besoin d'avoir et
d'ailleurs ça interroge me semble-t-il
un peu même le titre de votre commission
c'est à dire sur autour de la résorption
des inégalités des chances alors que
monsieur l'enjeu aujourd'hui majeur
c'est plutôt de combattre ces inégalités
là pour faire en sorte qu'elles
disparaissent donc voila et du cou ou
encore même sur une mesure toute récente
sur la question des apl on a évoqué la
question du logement c'est aujourd'hui
la réforme des apl c'est plus de 700
millions d'euros d'économies qui vont
être faits sur le budget de l'état sur
les jeunes ou principalement sur les
jeunes
ce qui est quand même assez interrogeant
dans la politique dans la période
actuelle
alors même que dans la même période
c'est à dire depuis les années 2000 il
ya des grands changements dans la
jeunesse ça a continué en tout cas le
mouvement de fragilisation de
paupérisation d'une grande partie
d'entre elles la crise de 2008 a été
particulièrement sévère en direction des
jeunes et notamment les publics et qui
étaient les plus éloignées on a parlé
des jeunes ruraux des jeunes des qpr a
mais aussi les mineurs isolés par
exemple aujourd'hui qui est une vraie
problématique les jeunes sortant de la
zone dont on sait que un quart des gens
qui se trouve être dans la rue sorte de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance n'est pas un
trait interrogeant par rapport à notre
système social
et tout ça c'est une vraie vraie
question et du coup c'est je vous
remercie de prendre cette question au
sénat parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
enjeu très fort à remettre cette
question sur la table d'une politique
jeunesse le plus large vient la question
qu'est ce qu'on fait et me semble-t-il
on a tout intérêt à mettre autour de la
table l'ensemble des acteurs et du coup
de pouvoir repenser une politique
jeunesse il ya énormément de travaux
pour dans le même temps qu'ils ont été
faits dans les années 2000 un parent en
2001 il ya le rapport charvet qui vient
interroger la place des jeunes dans
notre société par le haut commissariat
au plan jeunesse le devoir
admire s'appelle ce rapport du cookie et
repose bien la manière dont on va
considérer les jeunes dans notre dans
notre pays mais sans multi aujourd'hui
trois enjeux majeurs et urgent la
question de comment on va protéger c'est
à dire la question des filets de
sécurité qui sont offerts aux jeunes qui
est illustrée par cette crise
particulièrement mais qui était une
problématique qui existait auparavant la
question de comment on va les
accompagner c'est à dire dans le
logement dans les déplacements comme
essayer leur permettre d'avoir des
outils pour construire les choses et
c'est la dernière c'est l'émancipation
comment on va leur permettre d'accéder à
la décision à la responsabilité a
participé au devenir de notre société
aujourd'hui donc ils se sentent exclus
sur la première question est la question
de la précarité il ya évidemment et
c'est dans le débat public la question
des minima sociaux c'est à dire que on a
considéré que le jeune était avant tout
un enfant jusqu'à 25 ans en tout cas il
était majeur civilement mais mineur
socialement et ça c'est aujourd'hui en
tout cas une situation qui est plus
acceptable à la fois pour les jeunes
mais également pour les familles c'est
notamment dans les échanges qu'on peut
avoir au sérieux avec l'unaf par exemple
qui nous disent que aujourd'hui à la
précarité des jeunes vis que d'entraîner
une précarité des familles elles-mêmes
du fait de la situation sociale
économique
donc là il ya un enjeu il ya des
propositions qui sont sur la table il ya
celle du rsa il ya celle de
de faire du de la garantie jeunes un
droit tel que proposé par le conseil
d'orientation des politiques jeunesse en
tout cas là me semble-t-il ya une
urgence à avancer sur cette question là
le deuxième c'est la question des outils
et comment on va structurer des outils à
la fois sur la question de la mobilité
la santé de l'accès à l'éducation
la question des bourses par exemple je
me sens le titre pour les jeunes ruraux
en gros un moment donné si on veut que
les jeunes puissent choisir
il faut que réduire les inégalités il
faut que les familles ne se sentent pas
dans l'incapacité ou alors de se saigner
pour faire en sorte que leurs enfants
puissent continuer leur parcours
scolaire
et puis les outils d'éducation populaire
aussi qui sont très importants qui ont
disparu d'un certain nombre de
territoires ruraux ou alors qu'ils sont
très affaiblis et sur lesquelles il ya
besoin de revivifier les choses pour
faire en sorte que ce soit des espaces
qui intègre à notre société les jeunes
et qui leur donne des espaces pour se
construire
et puis la dernière c'est comment on va
donner une place aux jeunes comment on
va les inclure dans la construction des
politiques publiques et ça ça demande me
semble-t-il aussi de repenser nos
espaces démocratiques à la fois de la
société civile organisée c'est des
choses qu'on auquel on a essayé de
participer au sein du ce2 comment on va
inclure et puis dans les mécanismes plus
plus politique de prise de décisions
comment on va favoriser le fait qu'ils
aient les jeunes qu'ils puissent y
participer
trop rapidement peut-être en conclusion
de dire que c'est le moment la situation
est quand même très critique et
l'ensemble de la société voit cette
criticité de la situation des jeunes
le risque au fond c'est de d'accentuer
il faut aussi entre les jeunes et nos
institutions et que les outils de la
protection sociale et qui font la
cohésion de notre société
les jeunes parce qu'ils en soient
exclues au moment où ils en ont le plus
besoin ne croit plus demain à ces outils
là ce qui serait me semble-t-il quand
même une catastrophe pour la cohésion de
l'ensemble de notre société et dire ici
que notamment j'ai participé fortement
par le bureau du cce de la société
civile est prête à cela c'est à dire sur
la question de l'ensemble des
composantes du cec positionner
favorablement à l'accès aux minima
sociaux des jeunes la sauce dans toutes
ses composantes familiale patronales et
c est me semble-t-il c'est à vous
aujourd'hui maintenant les politiques de
pouvoir vous en parler de cette question
là pour en faire deux de manière urgente
de vrais droits une vraie politique est
une vraie considération des jeunes dans
la société
merci merci en tout cas pour l'ensemble
de vos propos introductif je vous
propose sans plus tarder de commencer
par certaines questions
monique c'est à toi merci alors merci à
vous tous d'abord c'est très intéressant
moi des questions j'en aurai d'état mais
bon je vais je suis pas tout seul donc
tout le monde va essayer de poser des
questions je alors je commence par une
parce qu'il faut bien commencer par une
vous avez tous parlé de la difficulté
des jeunes notamment en milieu rural de
faire des études de rechercher des
emplois pour des questions que nous
connaissons manque de manque de
transport manque de moyenne tout
simplement manque de réseaux bien
évidemment est-ce que du coup vous
considérez que ces jeunes-là
s'interdisent de fait le l'accès à tout
un tas de choses
est ce que vous considérez que déjà dans
leur esprit
dès qu'ils sont un âge de deux de se
poser des questions sur leur devenir
la plaie ils ont déjà tellement intégré
toutes ces difficultés que de toute
façon ils s'interdisent l'accès à un
certain nombre de choses
voilà je jeu c'est tout bête mais quand
je parle je
sage je pense à l'accès aux études
je m'interdis même l'idée de pouvoir
accéder à un certain nombre de
formations universitaires notamment
parce que de toute façon je ne viennent
pas du bon milieu alors que j'en aurais
certainement les capacités mais je ne
viens pas du bon milieu mais aussi et ça
peut peut-être peut-être ça pourra
peut-être surprendre certaines d'entre
vous mais moi je suis persuadé qu'un
certain nombre de jeunes aujourd'hui
s'interdisent tout simplement que l'on
soit dans une banlieue difficile où que
l'on soit en zone rurale d'aller en
ville
ce que je dis une bêtise et quand je dis
ça est-ce que là est ce que la barrière
géographique enfin la barrière
psychologique sociologique entre les
endroits où on peut justement faire ses
études su cultiver
voilà c'est à dire paris on les grandes
métropoles régionales à est ce qu est ce
que ces jeunes là ce les interdisent pas
aussi et donc tous ces interdits font
que finalement on n'a plus aucune
mobilité ni social owni spatiale ni
culturelle ni voilà ma première question
qui s'y colle
je vais tenter une première en tout cas
une première réflexion
moi je crois que c'est de fait les
espaces de mixité et les espaces
d'apprentissage des espaces d'éducation
populaire ils s'étaient ils sont là pour
ça c'est à dire que ils nous permettent
justement d'aller d'aller en vacances
d'aller à la mer pour la première fois
d'aller découvrir
je vais prendre cet exemple mais il se
trouve que j'ai des enfants et que
j'anime un groupe d'enfants j'habite une
toute petite commune de 300 habitants
du coup c'était des enfants contre 8 9
ans on allait visiter une ferme à côté
on a la moitié alors qu'on habite dans
ce village c'est de la ferme qui à côté
il avait jamais été jusqu'à la ferme il
n'avait jamais visité une ferme mais
c'est à dire que des espaces comme ça
d'apprentissage où on va aller découvrir
le monde et on va le faire en mixité
c'est à dire l'idée d'aider des
personnes qu'on ddd voile de mixité
sociale et c'est me semble-t-il c'est
ces outils là aujourd'hui je pense que
si on prend chacun nos parcours d'avoir
été dans des organisations extérieures
c'est parce qu'on a
en croisant justement des regards des
parcours de vie qui était pas les mêmes
c'est à partir de là qu'on a aussi bien
pu découvrir faire des choix éclairés en
effet il faut qu'on arrive à développer
ces espaces où on partage en collectif
un certain nombre de choses parce qu'en
effet si on a chacun chez soi et chacun
dans son monde social etc
de fait on aura l'ouverture à l'est
difficile quoi donc à la fois l'école
qu'à un rôle à jouer mais les acteurs
qui sont autour et qui vont permettre et
notamment par les vacances et c'est de
proposer des choses aujourd'hui ladakhi
sur des colos par exemple enfin y'a plus
de il ya plus très peu d'enfants ou
alors chacun dans son dédain des
parcours qui sont très très cloisonnée
entre classes sociales pour le dire
rapidement
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie limite et
sur lequel il n'y a pas beaucoup de
politiques menées pour essayer de
rattraper cette question mais pas
d'autres
la balance oui merci
j'allais réagir un peu en vue dans le
sens ce que bertrand vient de vient de
ramener met en effet en fait les je
pense que les barrières psychologiques
existe alors sont enfin c'est lé cas
cercle des jeunes ruraux chez des jeunes
de quartiers prioritaires et l'exemple
des enfants que comme bertrand vient de
données montrent que les barrières
existe finalement d'enfin peut-être pour
vous tout un chacun dans un contexte
différent mais c'est bien dans dans la
rencontre dans les espaces de diversité
aussi que ces barrières sautent
finalement et que et des espaces
d'engagement sont aussi importants pour
pour venir dire finalement chacun
chacune bien sûr tu le peux tu en fait
on chacun chacune a sa place dans
différents espaces pour aussi voilà se
trouvait se trouver sa vocation en tout
cas
peut aussi aller dans d'autres espaces
mais pour cela il ya besoin d'une
ouverture qui existe l'isolément pause a
menacé barrière l'a finalement l'hymne
une d'isolement individuel mais aussi
dans un seul milieu donc douze ans la
question de la mixité qui est importante
et ses espaces de rencontres et de
découvertes qui sont nécessaires
finalement pour pour aller au delà de
ces verrous psychologiques et que et que
c'est après il ya la question aussi de
où se trouvent ces différentes
possibilités
est ce que est ce qu un territoire
géographique ne présente qu'une seule
enfin que qu'une seule carrière si on
parle de question de les questions
professionnelles qu'un seul espace
d'engagement et l'année et du coup je
vais revenir là dessus sur la nécessité
aussi de la diversité des propositions
réparties finalement sur sur l'ensemble
des territoires qui permettent aux sites
à la fois de découvrir que d'autres
choses sont possibles chez soi et qui
ouvre enfin qui reviennent à cette
notion d'ouverture finalement que que je
prends tes avant
oui alors moi je voulais aussi dire que
je pense que ce que vous évoquez ces
phénomènes d'autocensure je pense qu'il
s'applique pas seulement aux jeunes
ruraux des jeunes d'équipé mais en fait
c'est globalement toute la question des
discriminations qui peut être prise sous
cet angle mais il faut pas être que dans
cette idée que tout vient forcément des
jeunes et je pense qu'il y avait deux
phénomènes qui sont concordance à la
fois cette autocensure ne pas aller vers
certaines opportunités que pourtant il
pourrait avoir mais aussi des espaces où
il ya des préjugés et des
discriminations je pense notamment à l'
embauche donc clairement sur sur le
marché du travail
c'est ce qu'évoque et charles tout à
l'heure on sur les consonance maghrébine
de certains noms qui vont faire que
certains jeunes ne sont pas recrutés
donc je pense qu'il faut pas ignorer
aussi ces facteurs-là qui pèse sur le
l'insertion des jeunes et nous ce qu'on
identifie comme levier au delà de tout
ce qui a été évoqué qui je pense est
très important sur le vivre ensemble je
le besoin de mixité de soutenir en fait
ces espaces d'engagement que sont les
organisations que vous voyez ici autour
de cette table mais passionnant plus
largement puisqu'il ya aussi au niveau
local un tissu associatif à soutenir je
pense que c'est aussi au niveau de
l'orientation et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a insisté là dessus c'est vraiment
permettre aux jeunes de connaître ces
opportunités dans l'école qui est quand
même le l'espace où ils sont tous
présents et c'est via l'orientation
aussi qu'on peut leur faire connaître
toutes les opportunités qui s'offrent à
eux dans leur vie future
donc c'est pour ça qu'on voulait
insister sur ce besoin d'accompagnement
et de penser à une orientation à tous
les tous les moments de la vie et
notamment une orientation qui soit aussi
au fait des discriminations que peuvent
subir les jeunes et c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste aussi sur le besoin de former
les conseillers d'orientation sur les
discriminations par exemple voilà
très succinctement pour compléter
l'effectif dans les mêmes milieux ruraux
qui sont déjà en proie à l'impossibilité
de pouvoir se mouvoir et donc d'avoir
accès à l'information
donc effectivement s'interdisent de
fêtes de choses dont ils n'ont même pas
connaissance également puis par la suite
une fois que cette information peut être
acquise bien la question de ce filet
sécurité un jeune qui veut pouvoir
un petit peu des prix et c'est elle est
allée faire des études faire se mouvoir
tout simplement est toujours confronté à
la question de peser financièrement au
niveau de son foyer fiscal de référence
et effectivement ça constitue une des
fortes source d' auto-censure qu'on peut
retrouver aujourd'hui dans une grande
partie de la population jeune
[Musique]